sous le soleil de roubaix une vraie
répétition
nous sommes le 26 juin la compagnie
théâtre du cambrésis le tec peaufine les
dernières séquences leucate jumelles
quatre jumelles la pièce sulfureuse de
copies que la troupe présente cet été en
avignon
c'est donc parti pour l' aventure durant
près d'un mois ils vont habiter cette
maison dans le vieux village des angles
4500 euros pour la location et la vie en
commun et et en prime on n'est pas payé
et en plus on doit faire la vaisselle la
lessive monter démonter faire les décors
laver les voitures et on ne peut être
arrêter et mettre des affiches
tous les jours il faut donc préparer les
accessoires alors on a du sens de la
phrase le décor est avec le théâtre du
cambrésis ça déménage chaque soir 800 kg
pour les onze moniteurs à installer en
silence car un espace alliant en plein
coeur d'avignon d'autres compagnies sont
en train de jouer pour la mise en scène
de quatre jumelles le théâtre du
cambrésis jouent avec la vie gay où il a
donc fallu beaucoup de réglages comme
ici au gymnase de roubaix pour donner à
la pièce un ton disons très particulier
c'est une pièce très très burlesque
c'est promis il n'est pas
psychologiquement les personnages
il ya un côté cyclique aussi c'est comme
un chien enfin un véritable ballet
infernal qu'il a fallu adapter pour le
festival d'avignon dans l'off les salles
sont souvent petite celle ci fait à
peine 60 m² pour finir publics et
acteurs de quoi en prendre plein les
yeux et la tête ce soir là une poignée
de spectateurs avaient choisi parmi les
700 représentations du off quatre
jumelles
une véritable performance de 50 minutes
où l'engagement physique des acteurs
laissent des traces
on se fait des souvenirs ont fait part
les blues des choses comme ça
parce que c'est un film est filmé bien
[Musique]
les passes sans rien du tech jurons 22
fois les quatre jumelles dans le off
d'avignon
[Musique]